this show is so addictive i'm sure
you're getting that from everybody but
right from the get-go i was like i think
this might be my new favorite show like
it's so
so good um it's being billed as gossip
girl in the regency era
do you think that that's a fair accurate
description i think yeah i mean
i love gossip girl so yeah any any
comparison to that
we're sort of winning but i think yeah i
think the idea that there's
um this sort of tabloid press and
there's someone that's
um you know having kind of a kind of
terrifying narrative on all the other
characters
is something that's definitely evident
in gossip girl but also evident in
everyday life with twitter
and um and i think the fact that you
know we live in a time now where there's
still the same sort of
council culture that and the clout of um
social media
um uh it's really comparable to lady
whistle down so yeah gossip girl
um downton abbey um and avatar
[Music]
we'll take them all that's amazing well
julie andrews voicing uh lady whistle
down is like the perfect casting of all
time
um on a scale of one to ten how sassy
would you say her character is
i think she's kind of everything isn't
she and everything's beginning with her
she's salacious sassy
um saucy and um succulent
she's got the most amazing voice and you
know it's iconic isn't it and
it's a voice that we've all grown up
with and to hear her
uh in the finished sort of edit of
bridgeton it's just it brings
the whole show up to a new level um and
you know she is
premium um so her uh you know being
being involved in this is like kind of
perfect but yeah she's she's
she is saucy she's hot sauce yeah i love
that um okay so who would you say is
saucier then uh
lady whistle down or gossip girl herself
kristen bell
oh kristen bell's so good she's got like
the she's like
she's the ultimate source because she
can do anything and everything
the fact that she can sing on top of
that um i think ladies and gentlemen
no it's just not fair but i think lady
whistleblown is kind of like
you know she's kind of well because it's
like regency vibe i feel like source
wasn't the condiment on the table
so she's kind of more like uh i don't
know like a kind of uh
bewitching sort of tea
but yeah she's she's um she's kind of
you know she's actually quite
she's kind of fair i think um
and you know she's never really off the
mark um but she does
you know she i do i'd love to know where
where she is
and without any spoilers um you know we
do we may or we
i think me and you know who she is yeah
yeah yeah
i couldn't believe it when i found out i
was like are you kidding me yeah i know
that's that's what's so good about this
show um how refreshing is it for you to
be working on a show that's pushing the
boundaries especially
um on on a show that's typically more
traditional with this
genre of tv yeah i think um
i'm incredibly proud i think shondaland
um as a production company and also what
they stand for is
what i stand for and i think what a lot
of people do is that you know
there's inclusivity and diversity and
everyone should see themselves and
within the narratives
that they can pay their netflix accounts
you know to to access
um you know there's we've whitewashed
period dramas for such a long time
um and there's so many things it's not a
history lesson but there are so many
aspects of history that we can bring to
the fore and
will mondrich the um you know the
ex-slave
boxer who was american in real life but
you know they put him
front and center as well with his story
with reggae and there were aristocrats
um you know of multiple races in in
england and queen charlotte had heritage
of
you know they went over to north africa
so it's like brilliant
and of course you want to do that as an
actor i think it's so important um
i you know would have loved to have been
able well i did as a white man i saw
myself
in in every tv show growing up um and
also you know
being a gay actor playing straight is
brilliant and hopefully someone else
you know way way down the line we'll see
um that you know
anything's possible i love that um
how much fun did you have the costumes
because i feel like just the show is so
beautiful
i can only imagine how magical it felt
walking on set every day everything just
looks so gorgeous
yeah but you know what's really alarming
and i'm sure no one wants to hear this
but
like you get used to it this is the
problem with netflix and shondaland but
you know
they're so generous and they write these
amazing shows and all the work that went
into it
you know we were spoiled um and the
first day you
you leave the trailer and you're like oh
my god they look amazing
and by week three you know you're having
a diet coke um
and whilst you know someone's getting
their wigs sort of like slathered back
on
and actually there's so many of the
especially the women who
had to like you know turn up about 45
minutes before us men
unfairly because they had so many
amazing hairdos and wigs and there was
some some people you don't even know
what color their hair is into the wrap
and when we went to the wrap party there
was a lot of like members of crew that
started pulling on my thing they're like
you all know you wore them and
i know they're real they're real
[Music]
but yeah but it was yeah i think i think
shondaland had the ideas and netflix can
make anything happen and that's very
much true
the aesthetic in the share of so now
this show has ruined you for other shows
now you have such a high standard 100
i'm just gonna do
i'm just gonna do theater for the rest
of my life
amazing well it's so great talking to
you congrats on the show i mean i just
can't wait for everyone to see it
thank you thanks so much